Let's think some more about the size and
the shape of the view point.
Think about the way you use devices.
Phones and tablet's are often used in
portrait orientation whereas a full
screen browser window on
a laptop is landscape.
Now, even though you can't change
the window size on a phone or tablet,
these devices.
Have another rather tricky feature
when it comes to responsive resizing.
Orientation can change, and
when it comes to landscape and portrait,
you need to think about
content as well as size.
Tola square images can work well
in portrait mode on a phone but
wide images can be a real problem.
Again for responsive design
the golden rule is don't
assume the viewport size
will always stay the same.
You'll learn the impact of image choice
and art direction later in the course
when you find out how to
use the picture element.
And later in this lesson,
we'll look at ways to work with
orientation using media queries.